[Music]
[Music]
hello
we're here well i'm here my good friend
dominic this is confusing billy because
i'm here as far as i know but for some
reason you're there now where's there
well where i am i'm here and you're
there no i thought i was here but go on
this is confusing
but this is uh a problem not for us
that's for the quantum physicists we'll
get one of them back on soon i mean are
we even anywhere but i'll tell you where
i'm done yeah i'm in canada of all
places aha land of the mountain it's
it's very cold outside but it's very hot
in this room wow i had i had the
the air conditioning on there yeah but
the people uh the the good people of
cass told me it was too loud so i had to
switch it off so i may have to remove my
clothes at some point perfect i think
there's a lot of people out there that
will love that and i would say just
embrace it just enjoy it you got a
fantastic body like a greek god so go
for it uh well let me ask you let me ask
you this billy because you and i spend a
huge amount of time in hotel rooms and a
huge amount of time traveling
talk to me talk me through
when you
check into a hotel whether that be for
pleasure or business you put your key
card in you put your bag down in the
hotel room tell me what happens for the
next 10 15 minutes what do you do i find
the toilet
good the bathroom yeah and i have a as i
have a look to see if it's get a bath
you're about to because i love a bathtub
and i and i know some people who who
would never take a bath in a hotel
because they feel like other people have
been in that bath and all that doesn't
bother me right i love it okay in fact
if i'm totally honest
i had a bass today lovely right before i
came on to say hello and it's a nice one
it's deep deep yeah deep bath yeah
you've sent me some lovely videos from
deep baths over the years and i've
enjoyed them
um oh yeah do you
can share them at some point let's do it
do you do you sluice the bath the bath
down though before you get in for the
first time do you give it a cursory kind
of soaping down of the surfaces you know
what i i just trust that that's been
done oh god i just i just fill it up oh
god i fill it up with water that's just
overly too hot
to the point you know where you can you
can just get in
you know when you
you
you lower your ass and you think oh no
it's too much my heart so never take
this
but then it just does
you know what i mean yeah yeah you gotta
lull yourself to the point sometimes
i'll add a little bit of coal just
enough
i'll bring it up to my legs up to my
thighs
just enough to get me so i can sink in
brilliant oh and it's too hot dumb it's
too hot and i'm sweating
i love it for a nice music player yeah
you like that glass of wine like some
candles i remember i remember that being
almost half your existence in new
zealand i would call you and you'd say
i'm in the bath i'll call you back in
half an hour um i can't remember
i can't remember the last time i had a
bath i think maybe the last time i had a
bath was it was in my 30s certainly not
in my 40s
um yeah to each his own
to each his own well you know maybe one
day so that's the first thing i do yeah
and then i test out the bed yeah and
then i find out where i'm going to put
my suitcase you know where because it's
just gonna sit there i'm not gonna
unpack it if i'm honest with myself okay
the suitcase is going to sit in some
corner until i leave that hotel room
and then i have a look and all all the
any doors or drawers for like you know
there might be a little secret fridge
with like you know little snacks and
drinks on it all right a pathway to
narnia possibly you never know right at
the back of the the wardrobe yeah i
liked it when i get into a hotel room
because i'm not a bath man so it's not
my thing
i like to
grab the remote control
grab the kind of guide as it were to the
hotel room see what channels we've got
and then scroll through to the channel
that i think is going to be the most
interesting for a while and once i put
that on i go directly to the room
service menu and i try and work out okay
so what's going to be the next two or
three nights meals if i have to do it if
i'm not going to go out for dinner
somewhere if it's too late if i'm
working what would i have and i go all
right i'll have the tortoise leaning
tonight and then i'll have the prawns
tomorrow night and then we'll have the
tomato and basil soup perfect that's my
first 45 minutes to an hour in my hotel
room well you're a planner dom you're a
planner
you always have been yeah that's true
you like to organize you like to know
what's going on and i like that yeah
it's true
i don't even know what the the room
don't even know if there is room service
in this i wouldn't even know where you
would find it right now do you do this
thing i'm sure you do it as a as a smart
intelligent man but here's my little top
tip not for you because i'm sure you do
it but just for people in general when
they're staying in a hotel room
when you leave your hotel room for the
first time
when you've checked in turn around and
take a photo of the number of your hotel
room because i can't tell you how many
times
you'll go down all you know carefree
whatever and then you'll come back from
dinner late at night and you'll think
i've no idea what room i mean i could be
in room 712 i could be in room 217 and
then you check your phone and it gives
you a little bit of info so there's my
top tip if you're checking into a hotel
that is a good tip actually i'm going to
use that because i've done that before
of um i've not got the best memory for
things like that you know like sometimes
you can forget where you're packed you
go to a car park and you forget and
stuff
one time i went i went to a supermarket
and i parked my car
and i went in and i got all my shopping
got all the stuff that i needed went
outside got a taxi
went home
and then the next morning i got up and i
was like where's my car and it took me
about three or four hours to remember
i'd went to the supermarket the other
day and left the car in the car park my
god but do you often take a taxi to the
supermarket was that a common practice
no
wait billy that is that is if you don't
mind me saying crazy so normally you
would drive to do your shopping for some
reason on this particular day you came
out and went taters get a taxi i'd
forgotten i had a car oh come on that's
crazy speak
peeling the onion
i can't understand how you would go
through that practice but hey that's
what makes the world go around we're
listening billy you're there i'm here we
have to do a little bit of housekeeping
very quickly because we've got a
fantastic
guest today
um shall i read this first oh you're
excited about our guest i know you're
excited about i guess because it really
is my kind of wheelhouse and you know
you're interested in those type of
things too but hey i'm going to start
with a letter that we've got here well
actually a message on on our youtube
channel
the friendship onion uh from lost
lollipop in regards to imposter syndrome
who said regarding imposter syndrome
it's not just about feeling you don't
deserve your accolades but also
convincing yourself you're a fraud i'm a
grown woman just a few years younger
than dom and often have moments where
i'm in a business meeting where i know
for a fact i am the most knowledgeable
person in the room in my specific field
and still have the feeling that at any
moment someone might jump up and go aha
you're not a real grown-up you're just
pretending okay so a little bit more
information there about what imposter
syndrome is
i think most people get a little twinge
of that sometimes i mean
you know as i feel like we're we're all
still
children you know inside these adult
bodies and there's moments when you
think
oh you know
am i really i'm you know is my job do
people believe that i do that kind of
thing right right yeah i feel like that
anyway you say you've never had a twinge
of that have you i don't think i have
but when you explain it like that have i
been in situations where i've thought
they're gonna or or when uh lost
lollipop here has has said they're gonna
say ah you're not a real grown-up you're
pretending i wonder if i've had that
where
maybe i'm on stage giving it
giving a talk about something or you
know when you go to colleges or
universities talking about acting you
think someone's going to go
you know what do you know what makes you
so an expert in this field type things
yeah so maybe a little bit yeah so yeah
even you
dom what about this we've got uh some
misheard lyrics i know we always like
that when people sing a song is saying
something else
so julie henderson
uh from youtube
he says um my brother sings tina
turner's what's love got to do with it
as
what's love got to do with it got to do
with it what's love but a second hand
with lotion
should we try it what's love got to do
you got to do with it
what what
a second
that works quite well actually it works
it works an absolute treat dumb yeah
that's fantastic thanks well done joey
henderson and your brother thank you so
if you've got any misheard lyrics please
send them in we love those kevin c from
ireland says hello tom and billy firstly
i'd like to thank you both for this
amazing show it's the only podcast i
listen to we can week out religiously oh
tie in both of your love of music and
the lord of the rings together my
question for you both is
you are both in middle earth and setting
up a band
which law there are rings characters do
you want to make up your band assuming
that they could play an instrument
and uh what role would they have in the
band and what would your band be called
wow that is a lot that's a lot to think
through i mean
should we do this today in a band
should we do this together bill should
we create one band
well can i just put it out there
immediately because this was an
immediate reaction
i'm going to say sauron on drums does
that sound about right oh yeah
yeah i think yeah that's a good that's
like a that's like a bonham drummer
isn't it
one drum of that yeah yeah
okay
yeah a lot of power all right so that's
a good start
could we put you on piano i'd i always
like to see you sitting at a piano you
you lose yourself in a piano yeah i'm a
little penis
um
let's do it i've always enjoyed you
tickling the ivories of course you have
i think fourth thing i think for the pr
guys
they would like you know like if
galadriel was a singer i think
for the posters and the album
quite enigmatic
quite interesting
yeah i like that guitar
guitar
could we go with gimli on bass
oh gemlin
yeah
yeah i like that too yeah and then
lead we're looking for someone you know
charismatic but maybe a bit mysterious
is that is that a kind of
faramir or an emma type vibe yeah yeah
pharah maybe now do you know who i would
put john you know who i'd put yeah and
only guitar
frodo
okay he i think he'd be a shoe i think
he'd be a shoegazer i think he'd just be
there trying to get it right and you
know you just enjoy watching them with
like those big eyes
his hair's nice and yeah throw dough
only guitar i think
i like that can we add an extra he
doesn't really do any
i think that's a great band can we add
an extra he doesn't really do anything
he's a little bit like bears from the
happy mondays khanna comes in with
maracas or a
tambourine can we have gollum do that oh
yeah that'd be good just just a
character for the band yeah because him
and frodo would probably interact quite
well and then what about what about a
name for the band we're not in the band
by the way but that's okay what about a
name that's all right we'll be the
roadies we'll have a great thing yeah
wicked yeah
um well we'll be the thing me wait the
wooded
road oh that's fantastic billy love that
great work
thank you kevin c there you go there's
the band
i've got something amazing to tell you
about
ollie pop it is a new soda and i'm here
to tell you it is amazing and not only
is it not bad for you it's actually good
for you
yes good for you and it tastes amazing
they've got all sorts of flavors like
they've got um vintage cola classic root
beer orange squeeze cherry vanilla
strawberry vanilla
amazing i couldn't even pick my favorite
every one i tried i like better than the
one before
they use functional ingredients that
combine prebiotics plant fiber and
botanicals which actually means they're
good for you good for digestive health
and they've got virtually no sugar
uh compared to like a normal coca-cola
which has got like 39 grams of sugar
their vintage cola has got
like
two grams
i mean it's amazing and it tastes
incredible
you can receive 20 off plus free
shipping on your order i recommend
trying the variety pack like i say all
the flavors are amazing go to
drink lollipop dot com slash onion or
use the code onion at checkout to claim
this deal that's
d r i n k o
l i p o p dot com slash onion ollie pop
can also be found in over 8 000 stores
across the country including kroger
target whole food sprouts and whitman's
lollipop is really magic
need to supercharge your hiring well you
need a super hiring partner you need
indeed
indeed is the hiring platform where you
can attract
you can interview and you can hire all
in one place instead of spending hours
on multiple job sites searching for
candidates with the right skills indeed
is a powerful hiring partner that can
help you do it all
find great talent faster through time
saving tools like indeed's instant match
assessments and virtual interviews
like with instant match
over 80 percent of employers get quality
candidates whose resume on indeed
matches their job description
the moment they sponsor a job according
to a indeed data us
so start hiring now with a 75 dollar
sponsor job credit to upgrade your job
post at indeed.com
onion
claim your 75 credit now at indeed.com
slash onion indeed.com
slash
onion
need to hire
you need indeed
all right so our very exciting guest
this week billy because you know how
much of a self-professed uh animal and
specifically insect nerd i am
is richard zack who is an entomologist
there's an amazing amount of uh
uh
stuff here information about richard so
i say graduate faculty professor
associate entomology entomologist and
extension specialist director of the mt
james entomology entomological
collection wow richard it's very nice to
have you on the show great well thank
you for inviting me today i was been
looking forward to it oh that's great oh
good good um now richard we do have a a
bunch of information about you which we
can read out but we always prefer to
hear from
the guests themselves it makes it a
little bit more personal and we'd love
to know about
how you became so interested
in insects to the extent that you now
teach classes about them in university
great so when i was a youngster i i went
to university i started at ohio state
university and i was had always been
interested in biology i had snakes and
salamanders and lizards and all kinds of
things
and but i knew nothing about insects so
when i went to the university i met a
professor
and he talked about you know well if you
ever want to get a job one good field is
entomology because insects do a lot of
bad things that people don't like
so there are always people that want to
figure out how to control insects so i
took a course i thought it was the
greatest course i'd ever taken in my
life i took more courses
eventually i graduated and i said well
what can i do with this degree in
entomology now
and uh and there were things but uh but
in order to do what i really wanted to
do was to study do research and and
really teach about insects like i went
to graduate school i took more courses
that i thoroughly enjoyed and kept going
and eventually i received a phd in
entomology and have spent the past 35
years or so
working on insects teaching about
insects have graduate students
undergraduate students and it has been
just a fantastic life there is there's
no group out there that is more exciting
and interesting than insects
here here i totally agree i i'm
absolutely sure that dom would agree
with you there has
is his favorite animals and
um
he he could he could talk to you all day
he talks to me all day about insects so
i'm sure you two together would be uh
they do everything i mean there's
there's an insect does everything right
i think for me richard it's the fact
that i mean i'm obsessed with animals
but the great thing about insects for
anyone out there is if you are
interested in animals they're right
there they're always there they're less
than a minute or so away from you having
an interaction with them whether that be
with a magnifying glass or putting them
on your hand or you know seeing them out
in in nature and as a kid growing up
same as you i kept lizards i kept snakes
i kept different animals but i i with my
brother but i always wanted to be
consistently having interactions with
different animals and going into my mom
and dad's garden and picking up rocks it
was it was like christmas morning i just
felt every time i would roll over a rock
i'd be like oh what is it today it was
so exciting there's so much to learn and
i think unfortunately they do get a bad
rap insects alongside
arachnids and i'm always attempting to
educate people on the idea that
you know they don't they don't even
though they can be destructive when they
can feel like they're moving into our
world quite a lot they don't know that
they're doing that they don't know that
they're annoying you they don't have a
concept of that they're just finding a
place that's warm they're finding a
place that has food you know
yeah no exactly like it like any type of
animal
they're they're just trying to survive
they're just trying to make a living
they're just trying to do what they
naturally do and uh and most of the time
it's actually us that's intruding into
their world more than they're intruding
into our world for the most part and you
know and i think for the most part we
we we can figure out how to live with
insects arachnids all all different
types of arthropods i agree with you
there it's it's amazing because all you
have to do is open the back door go out
look through the vegetation pick up some
rocks look under some bark and there are
going to be insects out there and once
you learn a little bit about them you're
going to learn that they're doing
fantastic things that they're talking to
each other they're communicating they're
finding food in ways that you know you
never thought about their uh their
models for all kinds of television shows
like the like the board from star trek
and stuff i mean any anything that you
want to look at you can find an insect
and and study it in that group of
insects yeah billy's interested now you
said the word star trek billy's like oh
hang on a second
wait a minute star trek not only star
trek but my favorite alien racing star
trek the block
i love the board so do you mean
do you mean that sort of hive mentality
that is that it's is that like
is there an insect that
that works that way that if
if one knows something somehow it gets
transferred to all of them yeah so
exactly so if you look at what what we
call a lot of social insects uh like
maybe like honeybees would be a great
example ants are a great example within
that colony
there's there's usually one that's in
control and we tend to call that one the
queen
she kind of controls it but what she's
doing is she's sending out messages and
most of those messages are chemical
messages that all the other ants all the
other bees are picking up and and then
they work in concert with each other to
accomplish certain types of goals so
kind of like the borg i'm not sure if
the borg had an individual that
controlled things i think they were more
you know they they work
does the queen
did they i don't i don't know but but
yes that's exactly that's exactly how it
works in a lot of those insects yeah
that's fantastic
yeah here's that this might be a silly
question this might be a silly one but
i'm allowed the silly ones because don't
ask me the real ones
but i i read somewhere that talking
about bees
that um
bees can take too much pollen or
whatever it is they're doing and they
can get drunk
and there's guys on the hive who are
like the bouncers and they don't let
them into the hive if they're drunk
is there any truth in that because i
thought that was a brilliant story for
us so i'm i'm not sure if that story is
100 accurate but so they can they get
drunk
yes so you know now we gotta we gotta
figure that you know we're talking about
insects where we're using your human
terminology and stuff but yeah if you
think about it a lot of those insects
they're going out and they're looking
for sugary substance and stuff and so i
mean if they're coming and they're
drinking wine
uh and which they will do you know take
some wine put it on the on the table in
the summer and the bees will come in and
drink it and stuff
will they get
drunk yes they will get uh you know
drunk i'm not sure is the right word now
when they go back to the hive i don't
know if there are anybody you know
checking at the door to make sure that
they're not inebriated or something but
yes that certainly happens yeah well i'm
sorry rich but i'm going to keep
believing that because it's just my
favorite story okay it's a good one i
kept being i kept bees for a couple of
years on my property and my beekeeper um
friend bruce was telling me that there
are
what
in terms of what billy was referring to
there what what he called bouncer bees
and the bouncer bees make sure that the
entrance way and the exit way is not
crowded with bees you know that there's
there's an easy path in an easy path out
i wonder if what billy's alluding to
there is maybe there's an overly excited
bee that's had way too much nectar or as
you said they've been drinking beer or
drinking wine and the bouncer b kind of
says go have a fly for 35 minutes and
come back when you're feeling a little
more well behaved you know um let me ask
you this rich because this is one of the
things that i i'm i'm always trying to
um
come up with the right information or
the right answer for people
when
there's
there's a disconnect
i always find in the natural world and
especially if we if we kind of zoom into
insect life where
humans are under this strange um
assumption that if an animal is directly
beneficial to them then it's good quote
unquote and if an animal doesn't seem to
do anything that they notice for them
then it's bad a good example of that
might be that people say oh well bees
are good they make honey we eat honey
you know protect the bee but wasps are
bad wasps sting and they don't do
anything and i always try and point out
well you know wasps are pollinators too
and they also eat animals that eat a lot
of fruits and vegetables and stuff
when you find this situation with people
you know getting educated about
insects how do you try and attack that
the answer to that question of like this
is a good animal this is a bad animal
which doesn't really exist does it no it
doesn't exist so good and bad are
concepts that we're putting onto those
animals they are good for us for some
reason so you're right honeybees
pollinate plants that's really good you
know half of the food that we eat we
need bees to pollinate those plants
butterflies are good because they're
beautiful and we like to look at them um
you know but but other insects are bad
because they bite us they sting us they
they transmit some disease to us but
that's so that's a human concept the
insects are only doing what what they've
evolved to do
and so like every animal every like
every living being they're they're
fitting in to uh to basically what we
call their niche this this is what their
existence is all about and to them it
it's it's not good or bad it has nothing
to do with that it's their ability to to
exist to do what they need to do to
survive just like all animals and plants
do for that purpose and and then to move
on to leave another generation yeah so
in your in your studies of insects rich
you know in getting a degree and then
getting a phd and then teaching people
over the years
what what specifics insects became your
expertise what's your kind of niche
market in the insect world so so i
actually my specialty area is a small
group is a group of very small flies
that are kind of semi-aquatic so the
flies themselves live around water they
most of them lay their eggs in or near
the water and their immatures their
larvae feed on algae in the water
bacteria different types of things like
that but the reason i got into this
group was because they live in very very
different types of habitats so uh these
fly larvae actually i don't know if
either of you have ever visited the
great salt lake okay the great salt lake
is very alkaline very very saline
nothing can live in there because it's
so saline except the immatures of one of
these flies
hot springs nothing can live in those
hot springs because they are so hot
except one of these flies there's
actually one of these species that lives
in pools of crude petroleum wow and so i
just thought
what what you know how interesting
biologically this group is and so that
was the one that became my primary group
uh i i tend to work on insects that live
in in or near water
and then what for the last couple years
what i've been doing is looking at
insects that live in unusual types of
habitats so those would be unusual types
of habitats but insects that live in
places and do things that give us
information on maybe why we need to
protect that habitat insects are really
good indicators of of changes that are
going on in the environment we can study
insects and we we can basically predict
changes that would be very difficult to
do so that's that's one of the areas
that i look at now are changes in
insects uh insect species insect
populations and stuff over time to
predict on whether a habitat is there
are changes going on there that we need
to look at or is this a habitat that
contains a lot of different insects that
we don't find any place else we need to
preserve that habitat because it is very
it's very different for us and so you
know and that might be uh a national
park is created or some type of preserve
or something so insects really provide
us with a tremendous amount of
information
oh rich i just want to be sat next to
you on a long-haul flight in benjamin
for like 11 hours yeah
it's fascinating
we'd have a lot of questions for each
other yeah
guys i just finished in the gym and like
anyone else trying to keep healthy i'm
trying to cut down on my sugars trying
to cut down on my carbs and i'm always
looking to get a little bit of protein
into my diet after the gin which usually
is a protein shake maybe i'll have a
protein shake today but i'm also gonna
have a lovely tasty bowl of my favorite
cereal magic spoon let me give you a
little bit of a stat run down here zero
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
and only four net grams of carbs in each
serving
only 140 calories a serving is keto
friendly gluten gluten-free grain-free
soy-free low-carb and you can also build
your own bots available flavors to build
your custom own bundle a cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter cookies and cream
maple waffle blueberry cinnamon plus the
newly reformulated super tasty honey not
flavor will now be added to magic
spoon's permanent collection simply
because it tastes so good and this is a
brilliant thing to eat if you want to
have a little midnight snack so go to
magicspoon.com to grab a custom bundle
of cereal and be sure to use the promo
code onyun at checkout to save five
dollars off your order and magic spoon
is so confident in their product it's
about 100 guaranteed happiness so if you
don't like it for any reason the refund
your money no questions asked remember
get your delicious box of guilt-free
cereal at
magicspoon.com and use the code onion to
save five dollars off thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
and i i see that you you teach two
specific courses here at your at your
university one's called um
insects and people are perspective and
the other one is insect and human health
so could you just briefly give us an
overview of both of those things because
they they seem really interested as well
so uh at the university all students
have to take a certain number of
biology courses or you know science
courses uh literature and that so i
teach courses that are designed for
students
that that are afraid of biology they're
afraid of science and what i try to do
is i use insects to teach about
scientific principles because most most
students know about insects they most
students don't like insects and so what
i try to do is work with them throughout
the semester to so that at the end of
the semester they may still not like
insects
but they appreciate them they appreciate
science now they appreciate how the
world actually works
and then in my second course which is
basically a medical entomology course
what i do is in there i talk a lot about
how how insects through the vectoring of
diseases have really influenced human
history uh basically since the start of
of humans you know we think about things
or maybe we don't think about things and
this is what i try to get across to the
students like like the plague okay the
bubonic plague this great disease that
has occurred throughout history that's
destroyed you know 25 percent of the
human population at the time well how
has that affected yes a lot of people
died we understand that but but how does
that affect basically the evolution of
humans how how did it change cultural
and you know the cultural aspects of
humans and stuff how you know how did
these diseases affect us in the united
states in europe in africa why why is
africa a place where where there's not
been a lot of developments okay and one
of the reasons is i would argue one of
the main reasons is because there are so
many insect vector diseases there such
as malaria that if you're spending most
of your time just trying to survive you
don't have a lot of time to you know to
do some of the things that we can do in
in what we sometimes call the more
developed nations so i try to get that
across to the students
i mean i guess you could put a strong
argument forward to say that the
mosquito is probably the most
influential animal ever to affect human
evolution i mean the amount of people
that the mosquito has killed over the
years more than all the wars combined
all the tragedies combined it's an
incredibly influential animal and and
even today uh you know the most
dangerous animal on earth is the
mosquito yeah
because of the diseases that because of
the diseases that it it's still vectors
today yes no question i mean i love i
love insects i love all animals like you
know i i i respect and admire the
tenacity of the mosquito it is one of
the only animals that i will kill on
site if i'm in a hotel room and i'm
trying to sleep and i'll hold my hand up
to that i am an animal lover but there's
a there's a couple of animals that if i
see it unfortunately
it's dying one of them is a mosquito if
i'm in a room without a mosquito on it
if i've got a mosquito net i'm okay with
it the other one unfortunately is the
fungus net which if you get a fungus
gnat in your house and then it starts to
affect your house plants it will kill
all of your house plants over the course
of about six months and it's a horrible
death for the house plants it it eats
the the roots and and rots the roots
basically if i see a fungus in my house
unfortunately it's getting smashed sorry
so why does why
why does the mosquito
in particular carry all that disease why
no
other
you know fine insects or so there are
other insects that that vector disease
is uh fleas fleas vector diseases fleas
are the vector of of plague but what
what mosquitoes do is
you so you you have mosquitoes out there
uh male and female mosquitoes only
female mosquitoes actually take blood
because they need blood to produce
offspring
and and what they do so so the vectoring
of diseases is incidental
to their blood feeding habitat
they they go to a animal host let's say
it's a human
when they feed on that human what what
the female mosquito will do is as and
everybody knows this she sticks her
mouth parts into the body she actually
has a way of finding a little vein or
artery and what she does is she will
suck out a couple drops of blood what
most people don't realize is that when
she places her mouth parts into the body
it's not like one needle i i would
people i call them straws it's not like
one straw going in and she's just
sucking out milkshake blood what she's
doing is she's putting two straws in two
needles in the first thing that she does
is she injects saliva into the wound the
saliva keeps the blood from coagulating
and the second straw part of the mouth
part literally just sucks the blood up
so the way that they move
germs let's just call them germs viruses
for etc from person to person
is
if she sucks my blood and i have some of
that disease in me the the
germ that causes that disease
when she flies to when she flies the dom
or fleece she flies to you the first
thing that she does is take some of her
saliva that may contain some of my blood
that may contain some of the disease and
she puts it into you now you get the
disease
and and all of that is just incidental
to her need to take blood meals yeah
it's not something that the mosquito is
doing on purpose it's a parasite almost
that lives in the mosquito so the the
biologies are tremendously complicated
yeah they're very i mean they're they're
obviously a hated animal the mosquito
from from you know from the very base
level of it bit me and it itches all the
way up to like you said rich some of
these awful diseases that unfortunately
kill people i've had dengue dengue in in
peru and it was a it was
one of the worst things that i've that
i've ever had certainly like the worst
kind of
sickness virus i think i've ever had i
mean i was hallucinating i was so uh ill
with it
um
so that was so that was a mosquito that
that gave you dengue yep right it was
just one of the few ones that
unfortunately i wasn't able to uh
to smack before i went to sleep at night
um but there we go i mean i i organize a
lot of my holidays around animals you
know um i
when i when i go to places
on my own on a trip it's usually geared
around trying to find a specific animal
and then all the other things that might
be living in the same place as that
animal very often it's
an invertebrate or um
or certainly an insect because i'm
obsessed i also just
i've always been such a fan of
um of knowledge and of understanding the
the kind of highly sophisticated uh
natural world and
in in doing that
what what i really love about gaining
that knowledge is you become almost like
a
like a detective like an animal
detective because you know if i'm in a
country where let's say there's a beetle
i've never seen before and an ant that
i've never seen before and they seem to
be in some way interacting in a way that
i i can't make sense of i because of my
base level understanding of how ants
work and my base level understanding of
how beetles might work i can then start
to deduce i think the ant might be doing
this and if that's the case then i
should be able to walk around this
corner and see another ant doing the
same thing and i'm just it's one of my
favorite things is making an assumption
in the animal world based on a base
level of knowledge and then following
through with that hypothesis and having
it be improved by the behavior of the
animal i i love that i love that
happening yeah and and i mean basically
you you just describe science right
right that that's what science is all
about right yep if i could uh i've been
i've been uh i was i left college before
i i uh got my qualifications because i
started acting when i was 18. um
my plan was to go to
drama college after that but it i never
did it because i started working but
my father was a teacher my brother is
still a teacher i come from a family of
of teachers and educators and i'd always
wanted to get a degree in uh entomology
and some sort of open university thing i
think even though even though ants are
probably my all-time favorite insect and
after that probably mantids and and
beatles i think if i were to
get a degree in entomology the animal
that i would study now would be the
house fly because they're ubiquitous
yeah and and their their interaction
with humans is is so intimate you know
they live in our houses they eat our
food they sleep where we sleep type
thing and also the life cycle is so fast
i find the the common house flood uh
moscow domestica just absolutely
fascinating so i have a ques i have a
question for you guys
where where in the lord of the rings
are insects is an insect actually used
for a very definite purpose
uh would that be
gandalf in the moth
gandalf in the moth okay yeah is that
the correct answer
yes that was the correct is that what
you had billy
no i was thinking about yours your
speciality there rich the um the midge
water marshes
okay yeah and there could be but and and
it's interesting because i don't know
who came up with that for the movie
but culturally
especially in native american
populations and throughout a lot of uh
human culture
moths
were
used as messengers from the gods to come
down and actually talk and deliver
messages to people
and and that's what happened there and
so again i'm not sure who wrote that in
but uh but they must have had some
little entomological background to them
yeah wow i'm sure it's in the book i'm
sure tolkien has it in the book right
yeah yeah it's in the book i don't know
talking has it in the book or not i
think it is i think it is because i
remember it being quite a vivid memory
for me unless i'm blurring it with the
movie but i seem to recall it being in
there while we're on the subject of
moths rich because this is one of the
common questions that i get asked and it
would be a great thing for you as a true
expert to answer this can you just
explain to people who are confused as to
why moths seem to be obsessed with light
bulbs just explain what is actually
going on for the moth there yeah so
that's a
really good question that i wish i had a
really good answer to
uh realistically
there are probably several answers one
of them
is that
when a when a moth finds itself in some
place that it needs to escape from
what it does is it looks for some type
of light source
so if it's buried down in something if
there's a if there's a light source and
it flies towards that that is going to
get it out of this situation that it's
in and so
what what we have here is kind of an
artifact you put your porch light on at
night
you know insects
are not perceiving that as a porch light
or anything it triggers in them a
behavior of flight behavior that they
just fly towards that light do they do
moths
don't moths also navigate by the light
of the moon isn't that a way that they
move around the planet so are they
you know there there's there's probably
some of that there's probably some of
that but not
it would not be a primary way that they
would do it
what what makes an insect an
insect and what makes an insect
yeah an insect
so so an insect
an insect is an animal
that has an
exoskeleton so an outside skeleton on
the an insect is what we call a
segmented animal and dom probably knows
all so it consists of actually segments
but in insects those segments are
combined into units uh what we call a
head a thorax and an abdomen so three
functional units
that we only find in insects and then
there are other little characteristics
too but basically a segmented animal
with an exoskeleton that is divided into
three body segments right yeah six legs
as well right six legs yep and six legs
yep six legs
yeah and so if you think about something
like a spider
well a spider is not an insect it's in
it's in this group we call the
arthropods so indeed a spider has an
exoskeleton but it's divided into two
body segments and has eight legs and
then you know i know dom has some
interesting other critters
at home i think that uh that are
variously they're arthropods but they're
variously divided into segments and legs
and stuff like that yeah yeah i have a
variety of different isopods or or as
one one of the animals out there that
has a variety of different names around
the world i think in in britain they're
called woodlouse in certain parts of the
world they're called roly-polies or pill
bugs
they're you know they they're bugs yeah
pill bugs i think some some people call
them potato bugs which is obviously a
misnomer because obviously a different
type of potato bug um yeah but uh
scientifically known as an as an isopod
right now they aren't insects because
they have more than six legs and they
don't have a head thorax and abdomen and
aren't they also slightly more
associated with uh
water kind of shrimp life than insects
yeah so
so arthropo so crustaceans are an
arthropod okay but the ones that you
just talked about are what we call
terrestrial crustaceans they they live
on on the surface
the great great majority of crustaceans
live in marine environments in the ocean
and that's everything from from shrimp
to lobster to crab those are those are
your isopods are more closely related to
a lobster than they are to an insect
and and isopods would last whatever you
want to call them
are a very very old animal that existed
on planet earth and is one of the
initial indicating animals of a
strictly aquatic animal that then
ventured out into terrestrial earth
which for me is what makes it so
fascinating right have a very close
relationship with water they need a kind
of humid environment otherwise they'll
die but clearly they they ventured out
into this brave new frontier for them
where they were like
our
ancestors come from the ocean we're
going to go out into the land and see
what we can do there i just it's just
fascinating
even
evolution for that animal you know yeah
and most of their ancestors stayed in
the oceans
right right
i brought a couple little things today i
don't know if uh if i don't know if you
can see these little guys oh wait so
these are called hissing cockroaches
yeah and they're a uh
this is the one that everybody uses in
in any type of movie or something yeah
where where they there they want an
insect that they're going to do
something with people are going to eat
which i'd never eat one of these or they
want to cover some body with with
something to make it look disgusting uh
these are the roaches that they use for
the most part
real easy to take care of they're but
they do make a hissing noise so
nice and i don't think we could
if you can hear that we can definitely
yeah
and
and this one's just peeing all over my
keyboard brilliance oh god
yep well well rich this is what they'll
do this is it this is a great teaching
moment because
so many people out there are extremely
fearful of cockroaches and that is
generally the american and german
cockroach because obviously you know
they they vermin and they live on your
food and they can invade the house breed
like crazy but the the madagascan
hissing cockroach is clean very
fastidious and doesn't pass on any germs
at all right it's not an animal to be
scared of nope nothing at all nice nice
but uh well piss on your computer
yeah but now there's p all over my
computer
we'll get it let's see if we can get
this oh so this is a uh
us
australian walking stick
and so this is a what they call a
prickly walking stick or a spiny walking
stick comes from australia it's it's a
large animal again uh
you know no as you can see no danger or
anything from this in australia they
would they feed mainly on kind of
rosacea so rose and berry plants and
stuff but
you see how this would blend in almost
perfectly uh with an environment out
there yeah and
so so so kind of
this this probably is probably my
favorite insect wow
well that is an absolutely beautiful
animal so
we're we're
talking to you right now from your house
right rich can you just talk us through
what else you have what what other
invertebrates you keep in your house or
animals in general yeah
yeah so let me grab one more here okay
great
i love it that's so good this is just
you though
i know i know we're gonna have to have a
specific guest for you next week because
this all me oh tarantula break it okay
so
so this is a a choco golden knee
tarantula wow and there are there are
hundreds of different types of
tarantulas throughout the world this one
comes from kind of the argentina area
and uh i've had her it's it's a her i've
had her for about eight years now
she is very docile
she
i mean she has bitten but uh but you
know you almost have to force her to
bite
the interesting thing about tarantulas
is most tarantulas are not very
aggressive and they're and the toxin
that they put in when they do bite with
a few exceptions is not very toxic but
the most dangerous thing about many
tarantulas is you can see her body's
covered with a lot of hairs
those hairs can be hollow and they can
contain a chemical which causes
basically skin irritation so the way a
tarantula protects itself from a mouse
or something that's about to eat it most
of the time it doesn't bite it actually
will will figure out some ways to either
shoot the hairs or embed those hairs say
in the face of a mouse or you know some
type of small mammal that wants to eat
it and it causes it causes swelling it
causes itching etc in that animal but
she's a uh
she's very friendly beautiful right yeah
now she's
she's a beautiful little animal yeah
just amazing in nature all the different
ways peop you know animals have for
defense and
everything it's just incredibly
what what a great way to spend your life
i think to do it yeah amazing rich yeah
can i ask rich because i i did this i
did this nature show for a few years and
any time i got bitten i would say to my
crew and certainly the audience i made a
mistake there i did something wrong
that's the reason why this animal stung
or bit or scratched me can you recall
what happened to to make your tarantula
bite yeah
uh so what happened was i i don't do
this anymore but i used to let visitors
to us hold it
and and so uh
you know about a 14 year old was holding
it and then got really afraid and and
went to drop it and so i reached as
quickly as i could and grabbed it so it
didn't fall to the ground which probably
would have killed it and she just you
know she was just trying to defend
whatever she could and she bit me yeah
yeah okay yeah see it makes sense right
you can always understand i always think
that whenever i've been in a situation
where an animal has been forced to bite
or sting me if i go backwards i can see
the mistake that i've made you know so
well that's fascinating well rich it's
been amazing to have you on the show um
is there anything in particular that you
want to tell us about your about your
university or or to raise any awareness
about what you what you do in your
in your job specifically i mean i i
think that uh
i think the one thing i've tried to do
throughout my career is to convince
people
that that nature is really beautiful
those animals out there
they they're they're contributing
they're doing things and
you know as as either an avocation like
maybe you have dom or as a profession to
to study animal especially insects it is
uh
it's been a very rewarding life
and so the one thing i've hoped i've
been able to do is just
you you mentioned this you know to get
people when
they're outside they're sitting next to
the pool or something and they see a
bunch of ants crawling up and down the
wall well something very very
interesting and specific is going on
there those ants are almost blind
they're they're following chemicals
smells and stuff like that and
you know it's it's so simple you don't
need necessarily elephants and tigers
and bears to explain biology you can you
can do it with these small little
critters that are all over your
backyards your gardens etc so it's just
uh it's a wonderful world i was on we
were on vacation when my son my son
who's now almost 16 but he must have
been about five or six
and we went to this nice place in um
and portugal
and
you know i had a swimming pool and
places to hang out and swings and
lots of places for kids to play
and he
got obsessed with these ants on the back
just outside the back door and for about
three days that's what he did he sat out
there and he he watched these ants and
you know he put a stick and see what
they do and what happens if you do this
and then
a cleaner must have came and put
something down it got rid of the ants
and he was so upset
like
as upset as i've ever seen him at that
point that all these little friends had
left him you know
so i think it is that if you if we keep
that kind of child's mentality of like
wow look at this amazing stuff that's
all around us
it's a great thing a great thing that
you're doing rich lovely and can dom
come to your university
can i can i can we maybe don't can get
that degree after all we'll we'll figure
something out come and get a degree from
it there you go i mean i echo what billy
said it's fantastic to hear someone
speaking from a point of of passion and
interest and we do need as many people
on this planet that love and respect all
animals because like you said i mean
they're they're all doing incredible
things for the planet of which we
benefit you know so that's that's
amazing to your message rich it really
is fantastic thank you very much great
to talk to you richard thank you it was
a tremendous pleasure how cool
tremendous pleasure for me to be able to
spend a few minutes with you guys thank
you thanks rich thank you okay bye
well
dom that was a fantastic interview i'm
sure you'll agree what a lovely
gentleman and it's just amazing to hear
people talk from a point of passion so
if there's anyone out there who feels
passionate about something that they're
doing in their life get in touch with us
we really want to hear from you i'm
passionate about something tom i'm
passionate about billy and dom eat the
world
billy and dom eat the world
oh
i brought my glasses this week oh it's
very important when you're eating the
world to make sure that you can read all
the ingredients etc so today tom we are
going to be eating well there's
originals
this was sent in by someone that um i've
forgotten who it is and i haven't
written it down but we'll put it on uh
somewhere but dom
have you got any memory
for yours what's the first thing you
think of when you look at a werther's
original william i think it's gonna be
and i don't want to steal your thunder
here but you did ask me first i think
when i
when i try and you know understand the
first time that werther's originals came
into my world it's a kind of
very um
very gentle very uh what's the word that
i'm looking for there's there's a
diffused lens everything about the the
lovely done lovely
it yeah thank you it's like it's see the
camera lens has like a pair of tights on
the front of it so everything looks okay
a lovely
no no no not like that but like a kind
of magic hour lovely sunset glow and
there's a grandfather with his little
grandson or granddaughter and they're
having a lovely chat and he says
come sit next to me and we'll have a
lovely werther's original together
that's what i think of when i think of
werther's original how about you yeah
they i think i think the ads were abs
they were huge when they
there was weather's original
long before the ads dom let me just
introduce you to the world of weather's
originals
in 1990 do you mind if i suck on one
while you tell us
all right well i'll suck on one while
we're doing it then because we need we
need to suck at the same time okay ready
okay yeah
it's going in down the hatch oh done oh
goodness you know what i mean my god
incredible
anyway
it's like someone solidified it
happiness
dumb
in 1903
august stork opened his own
confectionary factory in the small town
of werther
germany
yeah yeah thank you
by 1909 he was already shipping suites
to neighborhood towns and his workforce
had grown from three people
to 12.
one of them gustav nebel
whoa
your staff nable invented a rich
caramelly offering known as butter candy
which in addition to butter it contained
cream
sugar
brown sugar
just a dash of salt though
i'm gonna i'm gonna just pick up on on a
thing that you said there
do you ever pick up on a dash of salt i
can't i never pick up on a dash of salt
i can't
know
i can i can hold on i'll tell you for
still so i think i can taste there's a
bit of salt in it now
don't i mean is it is it a dash is it a
dash
what's the number one ingredient without
looking
uh i'm sorry i did look there i'm sorry
but i you know it's sugar isn't it
yeah
it doesn't say salt on it i mean when i
was it oh no
it does oh hang on after butter let me
consult this
oh yeah after uh sugarcane syrup there's
salt in there i remember as a kid
thinking
but why
why is werther's original so tasty and
ultimately if you're gonna combine
different types of sugar with cream and
butter it can't not be tasty can it i
mean that's just something
it's something very there's something
something i like on the bag it says
keep cool and dry
you think they mean the sweet circle
kiss yourself
does it where does it say keep cool and
dry on the front
no
across from the nutritional facts and
then there's a thing that says well
there's you know
caution hard candies may be
inadvertently swallowed and can cause
choking
underneath that it says keep cool and
dry which i think is a good um
a good mantra for life yeah it's a good
mantra i mean does it is this is this
the sweet
more than any other sweet that i've been
exposed to in my life
that makes you
feel like you want to reminisce about
things is there something about the word
is original that makes you reminisce
is it because of that ad or is it more
than that let's let's jump from 1909 to
1969 dom
oh okay
husband stalk unveiled a hard caramel
called the worthers et
from the german word or
real or
genuine
true to its name mother's echte
made a was made with real cream and real
butter
just like nebo's old wrestling weather's
earth day was later rebranded as
weather's original for the international
market and when it first showed up in
the us and around late 1970 it was
always associated with all people
but why why are you all simple
i don't know but can i just congratulate
you on your german pronunciation there
of the word
i like what you did there that's
fantastic well danke dumb danke
i think you'll find that that was bitter
in mine
would it be would it be fair to describe
this as a butterscotch i mean is that
fair
i think it's fair but it's more than
that isn't it there's something well is
it
yeah
there's a i always find like a world's
original
it's almost like your mouth activates
something in it
like there's little insects in there
that when it when a mouth
gets on a water's original it kind of
goes
melt the butter
let it run down the tongue
and there's something very oh god
very soothing about them but i can see
how you would choke on it almost choked
on that one oh you could choke it
because it's a hard sweet or as they say
in the united states a hard candy you
know um
but
i mean it feels it feels like you said
like butterscotch but maybe a little bit
more i think that might be one of my
favorite words in the english language
by the way butterscotch isn't that just
lovely and that just roll off the tongue
butterscotch
scotch
butterscotch i also like the word
billowing do you have a favorite word in
english language billowing
do you think you could ever use
butterscotch and billowing in the same
sentence oh god well billowing tends to
be associated with clouds doesn't it and
it's tough to get a butterscotch in
there but what about you is there any
particular word in english language we
think oh that's that's a real favorite
of mine
chardonnay
oh yeah i know you love chardonnay you
big fan
yeah i like um also i think this rolls
off the tongue very well
gastrointestinal reflex isn't that
lovely
just say that along with me you ready
yeah come on try it with me i'll do it
i'll give it to you one more time
gastrointestinal reflex
gastrointestinal
reflux
now billy if you and i were sharing a
room together and i was struggling to
sleep
and i said to you you do me a favor will
you just say gastrointestinal reflex 40
or 50 times i think i'd be lulled to
sleep you just pop it where there's
originally in my mouth while i'm
breathing in the right direction i got
gastroenteritis once
what why is that is this like a sword
digestive system
really bad diarrhea dom
oh no and everybody in the house got it
we only had one toilet we'd all get
mushrooms down at a place called the
barras in glasgow
and we got my sister margaret she had
terrible diarrhea explosive
well i'm sorry margaret oh gosh gosh
gully golly
and i think you've told me this story
before right you said that all
all but all uh
avenues of opportunity were used in the
bathroom to exit fluids right sinks
baths toilets windows i'm not sure
what's involved
awful
what a terrible terrible story i'm sorry
about that um
hey i was going to talk a little bit
about the advert here i'm going to i'm
going to continue with some of our blurb
that we go
when stork the company that makes the
worthers original began advertising on
american and british television several
years later it continued angling the
gold wrapped goodies as old-fashioned
sweets
but this time it had a spokesman to help
sell the concept a grandfather debuting
in 1989 commercial featured an
archetypal cardigan sporting grandfather
who from a high-backed leather chair
reminisces about eating his first sweet
and creamy and just plain good worth as
original he was four years old and his
grandfather gave it to him so it's
almost like a passing of the torch isn't
it it's like when i was your age my my
granddad gave me a sweetie i'm gonna do
the same for you and that is a lovely
thing
now did your dad ever have a not your
well maybe your grandad but
your dad or your granddad always have a
certain sweet in their pocket you know
like you like see my dad
if he ever had any sweets in his pocket
it was always just gum chewing gum
little pack of that
pig i think it was called pikachu and
gum oh pk yeah i like that little
aniseedy gum yeah and that's the only
sweet he ever had
both my grandfathers were dead so there
was no weather's coming that way don't
you've brought the mood down if you
don't mind me saying let me try and
bring it up
my grandad didn't used to carry around
uh swiss sweeties that much but he
always had
10p the old big remember the old big 10
pence piece i remember as a kid it'd be
massive it like fit in the palm of my
hand and he always had 10p for his
grandchildren so we'd come in to say
hello to my grandma and granddad and
then he'd line us all up and there'd be
four or five grandkids and he'd give us
all 10p and at that point as i'm sure
you know uh 10p went a long way you
could you could buy a nice handful of
sweets with 10p you get nothing with 10p
nowadays bill that's inflation for you
um and then
and then my dad my dad's a licorice fan
but um to give my dad his credit
recently he's been kind of moving more
and more towards becoming diabetic and
his doctor said listen you got to cut it
out with the sweets so my dad has just
completely cut out sugar there's no
sugary sweets he doesn't make cakes
anymore he doesn't have sugar you know
in any of his diet and um
i commend that i commend it well done
austin well done well it's going to be
kind of hard for me in austin to share a
ton of condensed milk no then
i think he'll make an exception for you
i did have a licorice all sort when i
was at my mum and dad's recently
and um i said i said to my dad i'm
really craving something sweet i hope
that's all right and my dad was like
yeah it's fine and and he said you know
what i can have one i can have one here
and there and he just had one he just
had the one and i was impressed by that
because normally once you once you have
one licorice also
you know you've cracked the seal but
i just said what one did you have
um
he had
the sandwich you know the little
sandwich i'm not sure if it was the
triple sandwich or the double sandwich
but it was definitely a sandwich i think
yeah it was a sandwich if you could only
pick one
what would you have i like the triple
black and white licorice sandwich what
about you i would have the sandwich with
the brown oh you like the brown yeah
you'd have to fight my mum for that she
always picks those ones out are they
kind of a chocolate okay
i would fight your mum i reckon i could
take your mom she's quite small yeah you
probably could she's not she's a lover
not a fighter
um i've had my second word as original
well should we give it should we give it
some scores i'm not sure what else what
else there is to say about this
quite deeply it's a german sweet
associated with granddads
let's give it some scores okay
flavor and or taste
um
go on i think it's a fantastic i think
it's a fantastic taste
i'm going to give it a 9.3
well that's high that's high for you
because i think you have higher
standards than me in terms of the
scoring
i'm gonna give it
i'm gonna give it a solid nine i like it
it's a nine
how does it look to you john
well i mean what what is not to like
it's in a lovely gold wrapper like like
the setting sun
and the sweetie itself
i wonder what that indentation is about
right in the middle there is it trying
to look like a belly button
or like a doorbell is that what i do
i like it because
i put my tongue on i like it
like if i do if i had to choose which
way i'd like
to suck a weather's original i would
have it with the indentation facing
downwards
mm-hmm i think i would too it allows
your tongue to grip it and get some
perch purchase
i'm going to give that a 9.2 tom i think
that's brilliant 9.2 so i was going to
say i was just going to say that i'm
astounded by how quickly i'm getting
through werther's original when i was a
kid i seem to remember it taking like 25
minutes to get through a werther's
original but now three or four minutes
it's done i'm on to the crunching uh
part of the experience your mother did
tell me once that when you were younger
you had very little saliva in your mouth
so therefore couldn't break down food
and uh normally you could only eat
creamed rice
yeah it was an awful affliction i've got
through that now
um but terrible terrible times
um for the young for the young don
monaghan um i'm gonna give it in terms
of the look i mean it's fantastic what's
not to love i'm gonna give it another
nine i can't find i really can't find
too many faults in it
usefulness two big jugs i beg your
pardon
oh okay
you see that
yeah
now now now you put it into context i
see exactly what you mean um
now how useful is it can you bring
i would say
if you're feeling you know sometimes i
don't if you ever had this experience
you know if you're on a long car journey
and you're like i just feel a bit crappy
and i need maybe just
something just something to keep my
digestive system going i think it's
quite useful for car journeys to make
you feel better about life you know
but could you here's what i'm thinking
with a pestle and mortar
maybe bought in the streets of bangkok
could you take three or four weathers
originals and beat it and eat virtually
a powder a crystalline powder
and scatter that for instance
on the top of say like a danny stream
cake
well i think you absolutely could um i
mean
but using that same technique could you
then you know mix it into an ice cream
or on top of a cake
ice cream dough you've nailed it
that could be the greatest thing
a vanilla ice cream not too sweet
yeah
not too sweet creamy buttery ice cream
and maybe you put a
little bit of sea salt on top as well
but that alone i'm going to give it
a 9.5
for usefulness because i think that's
going to make us rich making that ice
cream yeah
my goodness this is one of the highest
scoring things ever and i wonder if it's
because you and i are slowly creeping
towards being grandfathers i wonder if
that's what it is do you know what i
mean
um
you know what just
it could be just to keep it succinct and
yeah uh kind of cool looking i'm gonna
give it another nine so it's 999 for me
don't call the emergency services
[Laughter]
well what a treat that was werther's
original fantastic if you've never had a
weather's original get one in your gob
they're fantastic
get one
yeah go find one they're found all over
europe and uh the united states and i'm
sure in a bunch of other countries as
well
but it goes without saying that if
there's something in your life that you
enjoy eating maybe you don't you don't
know if billy and i have experienced it
ourselves maybe something you've grown
up with maybe something that your
parents gave you when you're a kid a
curiosity in the culinary world send us
your suggestions we would love to have
it on billy and dom eat the world i'm
gonna eat the rest of them all right
cool lovely
yeah
well i i think we might have run out of
time bills because we you know rich was
such an amazing guest so we might have
to say
see you a non i'm gonna see you in
calgary this weekend which will be super
exciting
very excited to see you there dom i will
um
the time difference means that i'm
absolutely starving now i just had about
14 weather's originals so i'm going to
nip out grab something e and get to bed
and i'll see you in a couple of days and
we'll be back in the studio next week i
hope
sounds good billy and of course if you
want to get in touch with us you can
send us an email at the friendship onion
at castemedia.com that's cass with a k
or you could leave us a voice no
speak pipe forward slash the friendship
onion leave all your comments
on our youtube channel
and then we'll see this overall to
subscribe subscribe
get your friends to subscribe everybody
subscribe and rate and uh if you want to
be one of the coolest people in all of
christendom then i would say buy some
t-shirts or a hoodie or something that's
got the friendship onion on it and let
people know that you listen yeah and
billy and i are doing quite a few
conventions over the next few months
here all over the united states and
canada and if we see you in friendship
onion merchandise we would be more than
happy to take pictures with you and say
yay you listen to the friendship onion
so get it out there represent
i love it
cool guys
bills i'll see you at the weekend and
friends we'll see you all next week bye
toodles
harmonize with me and hold me tight all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your host the baby you're my pearl
[Music]